[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Hi, and
welcome back to VM End-to-End,
a show where we have
a VM skeptic, myself,
and a VM enthusiast,
or VM enthusiasts,
come on to the show
to talk about why
VMs are cool,
interesting, and useful
for a cloud-native future.
Last time, we talked about
reasoning about reliability.
But I feel like I
still don't know
enough to actually do anything
with it in the real world.
So we've brought
Steve and Brian back
on today to help
hammer that out.
Hi, Steve.
Hi, Brian.
Thanks for being here.
STEVE MCGHEE: Hey, Carter.
Nice to be here.
CARTER MORGAN: Glad to have you.
Brian, I got to start
with you, buddy.
After last week's
episode, do you
think I know enough to actually
go and like take a small SaaS
offering, and go from three nine
survivability to four nines,
to maybe five nines?
BRIAN DORSEY: So I think we've
got a lot of the components.
We talked about some of the
patterns that are common.
And we can dig into that
a little more as well.
But the question is kind
of like, when and how?
So what if we got a
little more specific here?
Like, what kind of app are
you imagining building?
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
Let's go with a
payment processing app.
So it's a SaaS application.
And it's going to
exist in the cloud.
People do payments.
Right now, that's mostly
what it's going to focus on.
I guess it's-- to be honest, I
don't even know how to reason
about how reliable
that is by itself.
So I guess we
should start there.
Steve?
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah, this
is a good place to start.
Like, I think using--
in SRE, we call this a
non-abstract systems design
problem, which is the
best way to do it.
And I think, if you
think about this,
you're building a
system on your laptop,
probably, or on your desktop.
You're getting it
functionally correct first.
And then you have
to think about,
how much do I want to
invest in into it in order
to scale it up, to have it do
something for someone else?
Because having it just
run tests on your laptop
doesn't really make
you a lot of money,
doesn't do much
good for society.
You want to get it
out there, right?
You want to put it
into production.
And so what you really have
to do is think about, well,
how reliable do I want it to be?
And the answer should always
be just reliable enough, right?
That's kind of a jokey
way of responding.
But think about who
your customers are.
Like, what do they
really need out of this?
So you're talking about a
payments processor, right?
So like, who are your customers?
Is your customers
like your friend
who sells bracelets at
the farmer's market,
or is it like a Fortune
500 company who's
going to be like throwing
transactions at you all
the time from around the world?
It's going to be very
different situations.
You know what I mean?
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
So I love this specific thing.
So it's always a
business kind of tradeoff
or a goals kind of tradeoff,
is the takeaway here.
STEVE MCGHEE: Totally.
BRIAN DORSEY: Do you have
any like rules of thumb
for how do you know--
because a business thing,
they care about
like money and time.
Like, how do you
know-- when we're
moving between these
thresholds, how much is that?
STEVE MCGHEE: We don't
have a lot of good data.
It's more just like a sense.
But the rule of
thumb that we use
is that every additional
nine you add to a system
is going to cost you 10 times
as much as the last one did.
So if you move
from 90% available,
just like running on your
laptop, and you close the lid,
and it's not available anymore,
to moving onto the cloud,
where the VM--
the single VM that it's
running on is like 99%,
or actually more
like 99.9% available,
it's going to-- it
takes more effort.
And the way the reason about
it is really like 10x per nine.
So--
CARTER MORGAN: That's huge.
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah,
it's a big deal.
CARTER MORGAN: I like this
little simple heuristic for me
to reason about it.
But I guess I'm still
a little bit lost in--
like, take the internet.
How reliable is the internet?
Can we ground it,
maybe these nines,
in just like a simple like
browsing the web kind of thing?
How reliable is that?
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah,
great question.
Have you ever turned
off your phone?
CARTER MORGAN: Rarely, but yes.
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah, like
the battery dies sometimes,
or phones kind of
lose connectivity.
Like, you ever been
in a dead spot?
Like, maybe sometimes, right?
So like, your phone
doesn't have 100%
reliability in terms of letting
you do stuff on the internet.
So if you think about
it that way, like,
if you're building a system
just for yourself on the cloud,
you wouldn't want to invest in
making it five nines reliable,
because your pipe to that
service is over your phone,
and cell towers, and stuff.
And you're going to be driving
through a tunnel sometimes.
And so like, why
make a five nine
service for a
three nines tunnel?
And before you go too
far with this analogy,
though, the reason why we start
to have higher availability
is because a lot
of these services
are actually for
server-to-server communication
in a data center, where they
have much better connectivity
than you do between
your computer
or your phone and the service.
And the other part of it
is like, most of the time,
you have more than one customer.
So like, if my connectivity
to the service is no good,
most of the other
people's service
is actually still good
during that minute
or during that second, right?
So you really do
want to have, for
like these high-end
services, you
want to have them
pretty highly available.
But you have to think
of the big picture.
Like, who's the customer?
How many of the
customers are there?
How often do they expect
it to be up or not?
And the last thing
you want to consider
is like, your service,
or your business,
or whatever, is probably
made up of a bunch
of different services.
And so if you have
many endpoints
that your service might-- or
that your customer may hit,
some of them might
be super important.
Some of them might be
way less important.
So if I need to sign up for
a new account, and it's down,
I can retry, not a big deal.
But if I'm sending you thousands
of transactions per second,
and I want you to like
give me money back,
that should probably be more
up than the signup flow.
You know what I mean?
BRIAN DORSEY: OK,
so this makes sense.
So we're building this kind
of more reliable system out
of layers of less reliable
bits, and because we
have lots of users or
business need to do it.
But like, so we talked
about a little bit of it.
Like, in the docs, you
can find out roughly
how reliable a VM is.
But when you start to build
these shapes on top of that,
how do I know even
roughly kind of how
reliable a particular
pattern that I've built is?
You know, a load balancer in
front of a managed instance
group or something.
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah,
great question,
because most
interesting businesses,
at least that I know of, are not
running on a single VM, right?
They're not just one thing.
And if you look at
the cloud offerings,
there's all kinds of stuff.
There's like Pub/Sub,
and databases,
and all kinds of stuff.
And your job as an
architect, or a designer,
or an engineer at a company
who's using the cloud
is to come up with what
we call an architecture.
So this is the set of
services that all kind of
stick together.
Some of them are
like you put code
onto a compute
platform of some kind.
Another one is like you put
a schema onto a database
or a data store of some kind.
Sometimes it's like
a message passing.
So you have to define
the message cues.
So this is your architecture.
So the trick with
architecture is
you've got a whole
bunch of components.
And you can compose them
in tons of different ways.
And some of them are
complete disasters, right?
Like, some of them
do not work well.
So now, the question
you ask is like,
how do we know if we're
building a good one?
And just like any
software development,
the best plan is to use
a well-known pattern.
So we have these design
patterns in computer science.
We have similar design patterns
in cloud architecture as well.
So there's actually a paper
that came out sometime
this year, a while
ago, and it was
about the-- we called it the
deployment archetypes in Cloud.
And it gives you a couple--
like, I think there's six
or eight different models.
And it starts off simple, like
build one thing in one region.
And it builds up from there.
So some of the more
common architectures
are like, if you have
a stack of services--
and by services, I
mean like your web
server, and your database,
and things like that.
You can have one stack in
one region, and one stack
in another region, and
like a load balancer
in front of those two things.
And you can get really
complicated beyond that.
You can have things like
failover between those two
be automated.
You can have hot and cold.
You can have hot and warm.
You can have hot and hot.
And you can have more
than just two, right?
You could have n
different deployments
and have them all be
active at any given time.
And you can charge
your customers
across them and all that.
So take a look at that paper.
It's not like GCP
architecture specific.
It gives you the
pattern, though,
that lets you know what you
can get out of this archetype.
CARTER MORGAN: I love that.
And I love just learning
general principles for how
to architect and design systems.
So I'm definitely going
to check that out.
But now this kind of
leads me to this question
of calling back something
you said earlier,
getting a little less abstract.
If I were to take my payment
processor application--
it was just for myself
and my friends before.
Now I've got my
first big customer.
And they're going
to throw thousands
of receipts and invoices at me.
How do I start analyzing
going from where
my offering is at to
where it needs to be now
to meet these demands?
STEVE MCGHEE: I love pinning
it to this real problem.
And the pattern
you're talking about,
where you start with
a few customers,
and you slowly grow, and you
start to make like business
agreements with more
customers-- that
is common across everybody.
This is totally how
businesses grow.
And it's the right way
to do it, because you
don't want to start
in your garage
and build like
enterprise software
and expect it to
be like-- you're
going to spend 15 years building
this thing before you have
your first customer.
So growing with your
customer demands
is totally the
right way to do it.
In terms of actually
getting you to be
able to land that contract
with, you know, BigCo,
and handle the five
nines or whatever
it is that they're
putting in your contract,
this takes a lot of what we
call resilience engineering
or reliability engineering.
The way to think about
it is that you're
going to be building
what we call a platform.
And this is going to be a
platform of capabilities.
So these capabilities are
going to be technical things.
Like, you can deploy code
to your services quickly,
and effectively, and safely.
So you've heard of
CI/CD, for example.
Like, a CI/CD pipeline
is a set of capabilities
in your platform.
Other things, like
observability and monitoring,
so being able to determine,
what is going on right now?
Why is this one
weird thing slow?
Like, being able
to look at a graph,
and being able to drill
into it, and being
able to check out a
trace or a profile
of a live running system,
and being able to stand it,
like having your team be able
to grok what's really going on
under the covers and
use the tools that they
have at their disposal-- this
is all part of your platform.
And you're building
out capabilities
as a team to be able to run
this super complicated, complex
system.
And the more
capabilities you have,
the better shot you
have at achieving it.
BRIAN DORSEY: So
if we want to be
able to handle our requests
from kind of BigCo coming in,
everything downstream
of that needs
to be highly reliable to
the same degree, right?
STEVE MCGHEE: This is a great--
the answer is no.
It's one of these
surprising things, where
what really matters
to your business
is the front door, right?
So BigCo has a contract with us.
And whenever they
send us a thing,
we have to be able to respond
within some amount of time.
But does that mean that
the database behind our API
needs to be like six nines,
and the infrastructure
that database is on needs
to be like seven nines?
And then like, does the
power supply behind that--
CARTER MORGAN: I've never
even heard these nines.
STEVE MCGHEE: --need
to be like 19 nines?
Like, what's going on?
This is untenable, right?
And the answer is totally no.
Like, that is not the case.
So this is good news.
So you're able to
build things that
are more reliable on top of
things that are less reliable.
This is like a
general abstraction
that you can achieve.
So if your front door, you
want it to be five nines,
you can get away with having
like a four nines or even
a three nines back end.
And the way you do that
is through some resilience
capabilities.
So like, a really,
really simple one
is purely adding
retries to your system.
So if your front end is up, and
your back end is down briefly,
when your front end makes
a request to your back end,
and it goes, woo, error, instead
of returning the response
to the customer that you
have an agreement with,
like, I don't know
what happened.
Like, that's a bummer.
Just wait.
Just wait for 200 milliseconds
or some amount of time
and try it again.
If it still doesn't work
wait a little longer.
So as long as
you're not exceeding
some sort of contractual
deadline, you can wait all day.
And you can still give
back a correct response.
And the customer will
see that as a success.
So this is another form of
how we kind of hide errors
behind layers of abstractions.
And it's basically, you're
trading off-- in this case,
you're trading off
time for reliability.
And if that's OK with
your business, do it.
It's just another
tool in your toolbox.
CARTER MORGAN: I love this
idea of basically planning
for the imperfect.
We talked about this
when we talked before.
And I'm sure there's a
bunch of different avenues
that we could go and look
at this, like geography.
There could be
points of failures
there, or like you said, with
time, using time as a tradeoff.
The thing I'm
really curious about
is, it sounds like there's
a lot that goes into this.
You talked about a team of
people having to be involved.
And you yourself are an SRE.
So it seems like there's
more than just technology.
And I've been very
focused on that.
But there's also
people involved.
And maybe there's
even other elements
involved in this reliability.
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah.
When we talk about
large systems,
we tend to say people,
process, and technology.
So this is a great
example of it.
So being able to understand
a system, improve the system,
and build the system is-- it's
being done by humans, right?
And the model that Google
came up with is called SRE.
So a lot of these
principles that Google
used to build these systems out
and to scale them up and not
burn out all the
humans in the meantime
has all been written down.
And the specifics of
what Google SREs would
do in the past inside of
Google don't apply directly
to what customers
would do, because it's
like an entirely
different system.
And customers aren't
running web search on Borg
or anything like that.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
STEVE MCGHEE: They're
running payments processors
on Kubernetes, on Cloud.
But the principles
are actually the same.
And the principles can
be applied anywhere.
They're totally consistent.
So all of this
bundled together--
not just the tools, but also
the process and the culture,
how people work
with each other--
we kind of bundle
that together as SRE.
And so this is--
there's a bunch of books
out there that you can
get that explain all this.
And it's becoming
more and more popular.
So--
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome.
So we'll definitely
put some links
to the SRE books and the
article you mentioned
earlier in the show notes here.
So we've got-- as
far as doing this,
like when you want to actually
kind of push your app up
to another threshold of nines,
we've got the people, process,
tech part.
And then we've got this
reliability patterns.
And some of those
patterns, I think,
are built into the
system, like we
talked about last time, like are
kind of in the VM abstraction.
And some of them are things
we have to handle with our app
architecture itself.
Does that sound fair?
STEVE MCGHEE: Totally.
You know, you can--
there's always the idea of
build versus buy.
And a lot of these
systems, you're
just kind of getting
out of the platform.
So these capabilities
that I talked about,
if you're running
on-prem on machines
that you bought a
couple of years ago,
and you're running your
own software on them,
you're not going to get
live migration out of it.
You could build it.
It might take a while-- or
something like it, right?
But if you, instead, if you
kind of take that concern,
and you hand it off to Cloud,
you get this capability.
So there's a lot
of things out there
that you can get
a product, right?
And that gives you that
capability for your platform.
And now you can do that thing.
Another similar one is like
if you have the a layer 7 load
balancer, a global
L7 load balancer,
you're able to siphon
traffic from one region
to another, like
kind of magically.
It's amazing.
And doing this like on
the Wild West internet
is really hard,
because it's like you
got to deal with different
autonomous systems, and BGP,
and DNS, and all
this crazy stuff.
But with Google's
L7 load balancer,
it's pretty straightforward.
And you take advantage of
this massive set of systems
out there, this front-end
technology that Google uses
for its entire set of services.
CARTER MORGAN: I've got to
thank you, Steve and Brian.
This is my first time
diving into SRE principles
and the thinking
behind reliability.
And so I've learned
so much, whether it's
about the people, and the
process, and the technology,
whether it's about having
non-abstract or less abstract
architectures and really
thinking through it.
So thank you.
I'm going to
definitely check out
that paper about all
the different patterns.
And for people
listening at home,
if you check that
paper out, tell us
in the comments what you
liked or didn't like about it.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]